fancy some free beers this Christmas of
course you do you're in luck because
it's beer 52 award season where they
showcase the very best of the
independent craft breweries from across
the world with eight new and exclusive
beers that you will not find anywhere
else and all you have to do is go to BF
52.com sltr Jordie you'll have to pay
the 595 postage that's it and they will
send you a free case of eight incredible
beers you'll find out about beers you'd
never even heard of before for and all
of a sudden they're your favorite get
rid of that old lazy all too comfortable
doesn't do what it used to do for your
beer yeah and get that new beer in your
life take for example Omni polos outter
Galactic it always sounds
great and I'll tell you what it smells
unreal smooth all right we've started
something and if you don't like dark
beer you can choose a light case and you
can also add in a couple of tasty snacks
which is good and also it comes with
this ferment magazine which tells you
everything you need to know about the
brewery what goes into the beer and all
of the history of it pretty cool and
after all that if you've changed your
mind for any reason you can pause a
cancel at any time so go to be 52.com
sltr Jordi that's be 52.com true Jordi
to get your free case of beer
now that's a bit too nice bit moish I'm
going to try this one now well I bloody
love all of them so I'll I I'll I'll
crack on with that once this is all
wrapped
up he's a Content key do you know the
true you were going to decide that are
you what the [__] is wrong with it you
know how they play I want to be it
[Applause]
out see you you've got your mood
lighting on I have to stick mine on
can't be having the [__] true J
outdoing me nice box I sh to make I
appreciate the effort what do you think
of that ass there you go ladies and
gentlemen first on the true Jordie
podcast my best Bings ass I'll leave the
the underwear in just uh on the edit get
the women in oh please do please do man
um welcome back to the true Jordie
podcast I never get tired of saying this
it's been a few times now introducing
the Hall of Fame octagon Warrior
the C this come on let's go come on
let's go come on what what's up Brian
good to see you mate good to see you as
well bro and a good time to talk for uh
two huge fans of UK MMA and you are a
Pioneer and you were cage s to witness
our first well debatably heavyweight
champion of the world Tom aspel is the
interim heavyweight champ uh what was it
like seeing him just perform that
Miracle live like kicking the ass of the
the guy who everyone's terrified of in
like a minute unbelievable I mean that
is that is the word to be honest because
Tom's an incredible fighter right he's
shown that the way he's gone through
everyone the technical Brilliance the
agility and all the rest of it right but
against Sergey pavlovich I thought he
would have to you know move around be
light on his feet use all the space in
the Octagon use his wrestling I didn't
think he'd go out there and Spark him
out in 69 seconds um obviously I'm a
commentator so I was able to go
backstage and see Tom beforehand just to
say you know good luck and all the rest
of it and Tom's so humble you know he
said to me he said you got any last
minute advice for me and I'm like you
don't need advice from me you know what
I mean you're killing it and ultimately
I just said you know be yourself just be
yourself Tom I did give him a couple of
specifics but I'm like mate you just
fight the way you always fight and
you'll you'll uh you'll do more than
fine but then to see him go out there
and as you say 69 seconds to drop the
guy jump on him those vicious Hammer
fists and to become the interim Champion
um yeah just just an amazing moment the
first ever British UFC heavyweight champ
and he is the heavyweight champ because
right now you know listen I've got so
much respect for Jon Jones you know and
I'm going off the tangent a little bit I
got so much respect for Jon Jones but
he's not he can't fight right now so he
is the interim champion and that's a
real thing so yes he's the number one
Contender some might say but right now
he's the only man that's competing with
the belt around his waist that will
probably defend the belt at some time so
how was it it was Unreal I was so happy
for him I had to work on uh the BT Sport
post fight show and I I struggle with my
voice you know what I mean and people
think I'm always on the pace I wasn't
working I wasn't commentating the fight
so I might have had a few do you know
what I mean I might have had a few I
might have indulged ever slightly but I
had to go when Tom won ESPN asked me to
go on as well I didn't have a suit on or
anything and I had no voice whatsoever I
sounded like the most unprofessional
[__] you've ever met in your life but
it was a beautiful moment and then when
he walked out I went to give him a
little Embrace and I just said I'm so
proud of you Tom and you probably saw
the little video he kind of broke down
and yeah I mean he's just a legend man
[__] emotional watching that mic for
us as fans right like I remember going
downstairs at like 2: a.m. to watch your
title win you know and to see the p are
the first guy to do it to then now see
you with our next guy who for me I think
is the most talented fight uh I think
maybe England have ever produced but
maybe the UFC has ever seen arguably
like the talent in this kid is
outrageous so but to see you had this
moment together it was like you know you
started that Mike you know you have to
take a little bit of I know we but Tom
probably have been Tom regardless I get
that but you know you really paved way
so I hope you you know that well that's
really kind of you to say Brian and
people do throw that around the Pioneer
and stuff like that but there was Ian
Freeman before me there was other mixed
martial artists before me and I'm always
very sensitive to make sure that I I
give them the credit that they deserve
as well granted I guess I was the first
to be as successful as I was you know uh
but but but it still feels weird to sit
there and say I was the Pioneer there
was other people before me but yeah I
did have a great career uh and to be
there with Tom to form a friendship with
Tom as we have you know we're pretty
we're very close now you know and just
to be around that whole fight week to
talk to him leading up to it ESPN we did
a brilliant piece with Tom and his dad
and then yeah as I say just to be
backstage just to give him a little
Embrace and in my own little
narcissistic way be a little bit of a
part of it it was beautiful man because
I'm so proud of Tom I really am it's not
about me not about anyone else it's
about Tom and I agree with what you said
probably the the the I think Tom's going
to defend that belt for a long time
right even after the Jon Jones fight and
and I think he will go down as the
greatest mixed martial artist that
England or Britain's ever produced yeah
I I'll be honest I thought you know this
guy is unbelievably talented but he's
almost so humble it's to a fault and
then I don't know how many months ago it
was I was listening to your podcast and
you had him on and there was a twitch
and he was talking differently and he
was acting a bit more aggressively and
bit more arrogant I was like yeah and he
was like I'm I'm this guy like I'm going
to win this title I'm going to do these
things and uh I think that was a ke
moment just hearing that and it's
definitely taken an effect in his career
no without question you know because he
was so humble and he always said I want
to slow roll it I want to take my time
uh and I think having that year out when
he hurt his leg made him realize how
much he missed the sport and you know
listen being humble is great but you've
also got to kind of sell yourself to a
certain degree and you've got to believe
in yourself now granted people like
myself maybe took that to the extreme
you know what I mean Conor McGregor Ian
Gary there doing that Leon's extremely
humble but at the same point it's not
being arrogant and it's not being an
[__] to actually sit there and just
say listen this is how good I believe I
am and this is how far I'm going to take
it because Tom can back that up you know
sometimes it can sound delusional it
ain't delusional when it's coming from
Tom it ain't delusional when it's coming
from a person that's knocking everybody
out stopping them in record time
finishing them in the first round and
that's what he's done nobody has even
given him a fight yet we haven't seen
any adversity whatsoever can you think
of a time in the UFC when Tom was pushed
when we've seen him black and blue
covered in blood I mean he's a prick I
became the I became the champ but
[__] hell I I lost an eye along the
way I [__] lost brain cells along the
way I am my nose broken so many times
they've took my ribs and had to rebuild
it because it was [__] disintegrated
you know I scratched and clawed and
eventually managed to [__] steal the
title for a minute yeah Paul sorry Tom
has just wiped the floor with everybody
that is such a good point and kind of um
I'm a big believer in you know you look
at the past to predict the future and
looking at the USC Tyson Fury fight
lately I've been saying like how often
do we say usick in trouble versus how
often we say Fury in trouble so I'm
looking at Tom Aspen's career in a very
similar way and going let's let's look
at the best the for me personally the
best heavyweight I've ever seen was Kane
Velasquez in his prime I I thought he
was absolutely outrageous but that man
had adversity plenty of times and it was
always a war whereas as you say Tom has
written through people like a hot night
through butter and even John Jones in
his Peak it wasn't like this I've never
seen Jon Jones look this good this this
devastating this like emphatic this
quick like even his best ever
performances seemed to take a lot longer
and there was more back and forth so I
think that's why we can that's why the
the MMA Community for once is actually
looking at the interim champion and
going he's the real Champion Jon Jones
is isn't what he is right now because
he's had one heavyweight fight Aspen has
been ripping them to shreds yeah yeah
listen and I understand all that chat as
I said before we have got to give
respect to the champ you you know now
ESPN's MMA rankings I don't know if
you've seen this they have Tom aspinal
ranked number one Jones is number two
and that's granted it's it's made up of
a panel of journalists from ESPN Brett
Oto is one of them he wrote an article
on it and he said well when you compare
their heavyweight resume Jon Jones has
had one fight at heavyweight and he's
had one fight in the last three years
whereas Tom has been active another than
that leg injury you know against Curtis
Blaze he's been absolutely perfect and
that happened in 15 seconds so yeah it's
a loss on the record but it's kind of
like Jon Jones's loss right where he got
disqualified it doesn't really count and
it doesn't count I'm not taking away
from Curtis blades so yeah look listen
if you're a British MMA fan if
uh if you're Tom Aspen's wife it's time
to get excited because you're [__]
you're going to the Moon right get
looking at houses get picking out the
cars get get picking out your favorite
handbags because it's all [__] coming
it is how humble Tom is I text him and I
said listen mate I don't know if you've
realized this this was after the fight
on Sunday which he never responded to by
the way prick um but this is how humble
he is I said to him I said mate you're
gonna go on some crazy win streak you're
gonna get pay-per-view points on every
single fight you're probably probably
because you never know what's going to
happen probably gonna go down as the
greatest heavyweight fighter that the
UFC's ever seen and when it's all said
and done you're going to retire with an
astronomical amount of money money in
your bank account you're from Adon
you're from the northwest of England
you're from very very humble roots you
know what I mean but have you allowed to
think that you're gonna [__] have 30
40 God knows maybe 50 million in the
bank one day and he's said I'm not
thinking about any of that I said well
you might want to start doing it mate
you might want to just lie there on a
Sunday morning have your coffee and go
oh let's have a look what we might be
able to buy because yeah it's not for
the money and we all want to test
ourselves go [__] yourself it's for the
money it's for the money that's why we
do it do you know what I mean so hey and
he deserves it all and I could not be
happier for the guy it's a it's a really
dangerous thing to get into I guess
because you want to stay hungry and stay
motivated but yeah he's got the world at
his feet and I'm excited for a guy who
is a family man who always seems to most
of the time say the right thing and he
speaks like from I feel like he's a
really great representative for the UK
um but yeah he did put his foot in it
lately I don't know if you we've all
seen it by now he made this I've got I
mean we've all [__] up at one point or
another I'm the king of it for Christ's
sake but he's um he he made a little
joke with Nina the the MMA interviewer
who's a she's great and she asks really
awkward and uncomfortable questions all
the time so he played her game but he
didn't get the memo that men can't make
the same jokes as women can because it's
2023 and they're waiting for an excuse
to cancel you and he said you know how
what would it take for an MMA guy to
think of you and he was obviously not
being serious um but this is the thing
this is the price of Fame you and you've
kind of had it at times as well what do
you make of him just being in this
situation right now where he's being
quote unquote cancelled cuz it's in all
the papers he's not going to get
canceled is it actually in the print
papers I I mean it's in the the you know
I think the daily maal and the like of
uh doing articles about it or whatever
but it's I mean it's just he's a big
name now right well well they've got
nothing better to write about you know
what I mean they want a bit of Scandal
they love they love a bit of Gossip we
know this the Tablo that's what they go
for you know what I mean uh it's funny
because Tom put up a reel of Nina and by
the way I know Nina she's a great girl I
work with her own power slap and she is
she's she's a great girl she's got a
great sense of humor and she always
pushes the envelope so Tom put together
like a little reel of her other examples
and he put in there he said listen I was
just trying to get one back for the MMA
lad she's always making people feel
uncomfortable you know and neither knows
what she's doing as I say she's not
bothered by it she wasn't offended by it
and she took it all in it stride like
the joke that it was intended to be now
granted maybe not everyone's sense of
humor all right fair enough but you hit
the nail on the head because I showed it
to my wife I showed it to my wife and do
you know what she said and this is
coming from a woman not a misogynistic
Pig Michael bisbing she said well look
at that it's okay when a woman says it
but when a man tries to play the same
game that doesn't fly you know what I
mean so as I say there is the double
standard but still I learned this the
big news is he's the champion of the
world Brian let's focus on the positives
even if he wasn't the champion of the
world I learned this hard way when
you're a big you know strapping dude
people just think prick like absolute
prick so yeah he's got he's got to learn
the hard way unfortunately but yeah this
is a good it's a good little taste there
for when he you know has all of this
success coming his way that people will
be looking to uh to bring him down now
um one person who's looking to bring him
down is Jon Jones I guess uh but my my
my question to you is do you think that
that fight will ever happen do you think
now that the UFC Mel what we going to do
wait for steepe Jones till God knows
when to happen and let four five six
years of it non-c competition happen or
are we going to throw them because to me
I'm thinking you want to build the next
guy rather than preserve the old dudes
but I don't know what you think yeah
yeah well before Jon Jones even gets a
chance at taking him down I'll be taking
him down because he's joining me on
stage in Manchester and in London
December 14th and 16 Tales From The
Octagon right and if he thinks it's
going to come out and it's going to be
kissing his ass session you got no
chance mate he's coming out yes we're
going to celebrate his greatness but I
will be taking the piss I've been
working on some stuff when he hears what
I'm gonna say I don't even know if he's
going to come out on stage after it you
know what I mean but uh but tail from
the Octagon too December 14th and 16th
my ticket. co.uk had had to get my plugs
in Paul Craig will be joining us as well
so don't miss it q&as meets and greets
lots of fun we got Dappa laughs opening
up for us as well he'll be doing a
little standup set at the beginning so
it'll be a fun night anyway back to your
question Jon
Jones what was the
question will Jon Jones take the fight
with aspino because let's be honest the
Legacy Jon Jones has it was all when he
was the biggest guy in the light
heavyweight division now he's got to go
and T to talk with these other big guys
and I feel like that's the real test of
how good Jon Jones really is and I I
think he was hoping to have that Steepy
fight and get the hell out of there
before he had to fight Tom aspinal but
now [__] just changed it did just change
um so here's the thing right so Jon
Jones doesn't need to prove anything to
anybody he doesn't the career he's had
is legendary it speaks for itself he
decided to go up to heavyweight he
became the champ by beating s g for me
and and and and the the rumor is the
word on the street was that if the fight
between Jones and stpe did go ahead that
we could have seen a double retirement
okay but for Jones in a perfect world
you go up to heavyweight you become the
champ you beat stie miic the greatest
heavyweight champ that we've had before
you Swan off into the sunset you've then
got to beat the number one Contender and
then and then it's done right because
otherwise the narrative and this isn't
me I'm saying people will always form
the narrative that he was running and
ducking new competition a light
heavyweight he went through multiple
generations of challenges he doesn't
have to do that but now it's even
escalated further with Tom being the
interim Champion if the Legacy fight
between Jones and Stipe goes ahead which
by all accounts is going to happen next
year if he doesn't fight Tom then
there's going to be a lot of backlash
there's going to be a lot of criticism
and they're all going to say that he's
ducking Tom I won't say that Jones is a
free man he can do whatever he wants
he's sacrificed his body he's worked
hard he's put on some tremendous
displays over the years but to be able
to truly claim
the throne it's like it's like in the
olden days in the medieval times there's
someone else claiming the throne you got
to chop his [__] head off you know
what I mean you got to settle this once
and for all who will be king Tom asov
will smash him I do I've said I've said
and Jones I'm gonna have to answer to
this when I B been to him one day I said
after he beat Martin Tor I don't think
Jones could hold a candle to him and I
think the thing that people Overlook
with Tom is how quick he is like we
we've not seen that combination before
at heavyweight where we're looking at an
Anthony Joshua level athlete here we're
looking at a really special athlete and
uh you just don't see that and I think
the problem for Jones is you didn't beat
andaru to get the belt so we still don't
class you as the the real legit champion
and the one guy we do now see as your
competition you don't want to fight him
so he's actually ironically he's in a
similar position to what Daniel Kier was
in when he got his belt from is in in
activity and uh and and it's interesting
to see how he plays the situation and I
I do think one way or another it's a if
he does retire and doesn't take the
aspinal fight it's that mock in his
legacy of now you never you never to be
the man you have to beat the man and he
never beat them so was he really the
heavyweight champ but um speaking of of
enanu there's talks of him uh obviously
there's the the Tyson Fury fight we've
seen there's now talk of him having some
sort of mixed rules fight
against Deontay Wilder in the pfl what
do you make of that
idea well yes there's talk who's that
talk by the talk is by uh whatever his
name is Don Davis I think it is the
chairman of the pfl and of Bellator
they've both merged that's great what he
do who
cares does anyone care do you know what
I mean it's just like UFC bought Strike
Force back in the day they brought back
in the day they bought wec and they
folded those fights they're doing the
same thing this is not some gamechanging
thing and then the big news is they
would love to do engaru versus Wilder
right um in some kind of mixed rules
fight well I saw yesterday an article
from Deontay Wilder saying that he wants
to come over to the UFC so you don't
know what to believe right of course
he's gonna say that and of course on
paper that would be for fantastic I'd
love to see Deontay Wilder and Francis
zingu throw down and if it happens in
the pfl I'll watch it regardless of
where it happens I'll watch it I'm not a
hater um but he was specifically talking
about the UFC he talks about how he has
a good relationship with Dan W and I've
seen him at the UFC Apex on multiple
occasions you know what I mean the fact
that he's showing up at the Apex would
lead me to believe there has been some
discussions and negotiations going on so
I don't know but if we say
hypothetically that that's going to
happen I mean yeah sign me up I would
love to see him two big guys that swing
like that yeah the thing about wildar my
first thought was you know what I'm not
sure he should fight in heavyweight if
he's an MMA guy cuz he's he actually
like he's quite like uh Jon Jones's
frame you know maybe he'd be better off
trimming down because I don't know if
them skinny legs could stop a takeown if
I'm being real like um I don't know if
he's suited for it those little
toothpicks those little toothpicks mate
I mean they're very I'm not going to sit
here yeah they're very slender very slim
very very brittle by the looks of it I
mean Tom's got big massive thick proper
chunky legs we saw what happened to him
he blew a leg out do you know what I
mean well you know that that's going to
be like a little Bambi you know what I
mean planting around the Octagon I mean
I'm I don't want to sit here with rip on
Deontay Wilder I'm a fan of the guy I
think he's incredible what he's done in
the boxing ring
um but there's a there's a lot to learn
what do you make of Jake Paul trying to
drag Nate Diaz into an MMA fight
apparently they've made a huge offer pfl
like 10 15 million to Nate it's on the
table how do you think that goes because
I know you've criticized Jake a lot for
for the elderly box MMA guys but he
would then be stepping into Nate Diaz's
cage so would there be a level more of
respect from you there yeah look listen
I don't have anything personal against
Jake Paul I've never met the guy I'm
sure he's a great human being maybe he
is maybe he isn't but we'll just assume
that he is no you know what I mean let's
assume that he is I I don't I mean he
can be a bit annoying you know what I
mean but let's just assume that he's a
good person and he's just trying to sell
his fights and all the rest of it I've
got nothing against him but I'm an
analyst and a commentator in the fight
world you know so I'm going to talk
about this stuff and I'm going to call
out what I see that's the only thing
I've ever said I've never said anything
personal I've never said that he's a bad
person I've never said that he does this
that and the other I've just said he
Cherry picks easy fights he's a
businessman he's not a fighter right
Fighters go into fights not knowing that
they're gonna win that's what gives you
that adrenaline that what makes you
scared you know I mean that that's what
keeps you sharp you know every single
fight I went into I was like [__]
hell I'm going to give it a go I reckon
I can do this I think I can pull it off
I'm going to train my ass off but we'll
have a go do you know what I mean um
he's not doing that he's making very
very precise orientated business moves
he's being smart you know um now of
course he's gonna be calling out Nate
Diaz because this this one boxer that he
is fighting and fair play he's fighting
a boxer there's 10 and one guy I saw
yesterday the do it in a 3,000 seat
Arena and they've sold hardly any
tickets that says Jake Paul can't sell
tickets by himself not it's not hate
they're just saying if that story what I
saw yesterday is accurate then maybe
that's what it points towards so they
want Nate Diaz Nate Diaz is gonna be the
draw how does he do against him I don't
know Nate Diaz can't wrestle Nate Diaz
isn't a wrestler so for people that
don't understand if they watch you
because of your boxing stuff yeah we
strike on the feet Punch Kick kn elbow
then you're on the ground you got the
submissions the jiujitsu we call it to
get them from the ground to the floor
you've got to wrestle Jake Paul did some
wrestling in college or high school so
he can wrestle a little bit Nate Diaz
wrestles a little bit because he does
mix martial arts but he's not a wrestler
if it hits the ground Jak Paul will get
submitted very quickly just like Kor
McGregor did just like many people did
on the feet where we saw how the boxing
went Diaz isn't much of a kicker so
again this is
like all orientated based upon the
boxing match he because well I beat him
there I could beat him on the feet in uh
in the cage I could probably stop the
takedown so that's why he's being like
that uh and and Diaz isn't interested
you know why because it's embarrassing
for Nate Diaz it's embarrassing he was
embarrassed in that boxing match look at
the way he walked out the press
conference halfway through or like the
media day whatever it was he was like oh
[__] I'm used to going up against the
best fighters in the world I'm used to
going up against people like Conor
McGregor and I've got the Disney boy
going on trying to talk tough to me he's
like yeah [__] this I'm out of it walks
off and listen he got beat fair and
square he did I thought Diaz looked
terrible he didn't look good he looked
like he didn't take it seriously but
that's that's his problem not Jake
Paul's um I don't think Diaz is gonna do
that again he can fight anywhere he can
come back to the that's the problem is
like the the there's an excuse there if
like okay well boxing is Jake Paul's
thing but I'm the guy in the cage if
Jake Paul whoops him in the cage
that's a real humbling experience for a
guy like Nate Diaz who's viewed as a
legend in the UFC oh no for sure that's
always a gamble that's always a risk I
just feel like with Diaz being the way
he is with the infrequent schedule that
he has for his fights he's probably only
going to fight two or three more times
I'm not sure how old he is off the top
of my head mid to late 30s you know what
I mean um all he's got to do is come
back to the UFC fight Conor McGregor
he's got to make 2530 million dos
so why is he gonna why why is he going
to mess around with a Disney
boy you make a good point like [__] me I
mean that is the that is the fight isn't
it and um you know you mentioned Conor
McGregor actually I'm going to skip
ahead cuz I was going to bring him up
I'm actually wondering right now like
how good is it even possible for him to
be at this stage when you've got like
Chandler is sacrificed a year waiting
for this fight and that still hasn't
materialized now wrot it down um he's
got four fights in the last seven years
McGregor by the time he fights it'll be
seven years for fights one of them is a
win against Donald Cerrone which let's
be honest everyone has beaten him who's
any good very like in the last few years
um and then you've got the leg break if
he loses the next fight against Chandler
Connor would then be 10 wins and five
losses in the UFC which for someone who
likes to put himself in the goat status
it's not a bad record by any means but
it for him for his self-esteem it's it's
not what he he puts himself as um but
yeah regardless like how good can Connor
actually be in a comeback fight against
Chandler like and what are you expecting
so you raise some very good points valid
points indeed um let's remember he did
become a two-weight Division champion he
did set the spot on fire that's why he
became the biggest star that's why he
got all this money that's why he turned
into the EO Mania let's be honest and
we've both been on the receiving ends of
the voice notes do you know what I mean
so so but I couldn't give a [__] what
McGregor says um but here's the reality
you're right by the time he fights it'll
be three years away from the octagon
with the leg break as well then on top
of that you think about all the luxury
that he has you know what I mean all the
money that he's made the the insane Fame
that he has this these are all massive
distractions to being a fighter they
just are you know um so how good's he
going to be we don't know more than
likely one would assume that he's not
going to do very well that he's not
going to come back and be the Conor
McGregor of
2016 that's a fair assumption to come up
with but also also you've got to say
this he was the guy that took the UFC by
storm he did become a two-weight
Division champion and he's not going to
fight until what is it July now or
something from now until July is a very
different amount of time right three
weeks ago I was hung over fat sloppy do
you know what I mean look looks like
[__] bro I I've been [__] running
every day look at me I got my cheekbones
back my six back's popping I [__] I'm
[__] ready to make a comeback bro
right if I could do that in two weeks
just think what McGregor can do but all
jokes aside he can If he if he really
Knuckles down if he really Knuckles down
he can come back and give a good account
of himself I don't think he'll ever
reach his prime again can he beat
Michael Chandler sure it's two human
beings if he loses to Michael Chandler
it doesn't really matter if he beats
Michael Chandler he'll probably fight
for the belt if he loses to Michael
Chandler he'll probably fight Nate Diaz
and if he loses to Nate Diaz there's a
fourth fight with Dustin poier Conor
McGregor's got options Galore he's got
ways to make money for the next few
years and I guarantee and this is
probably part of the problem for him if
you're looking from the outside he
doesn't give a [__] because either way
he's golden he's got money and right
granted at some point that's going to
run out but there's massive massive
fights that that always always going to
be at the fingertips of Conor McGregor I
agree to some extent I I do think that
the his self-esteem is intertwined with
how good of a fighter he believes he is
and I think part of the reason we've
seen him off his face uh in the past
couple of years is is probably him
struggling with that which I'm not I'm
not gloating even though I think he's a
dick I don't wish that on him by any
means and I do respect like what he
achieved in the UFC was unbelievable but
even looking at his first performance
against Su porier one and how bad his
timing was in that fight where Dustin
took him apart um not that he was
horrendous in that fight but he just
wasn't the sharp Conor I I'm I'm not
expecting a lot and to be fair to the
lad if he comes back and [__] Michael
Chandler up that's a hell of a comeback
story like I you know it really will be
[__] I won't take anything away from
it but you know with that injury I can
only expect it to be pretty bad um but I
want to move on to another uh story line
Rec just let me say one point on that
Brian and you're right I do agree I do
agree and generally this is what we know
in Combat Sports and Sports in general
you have one Peak you know you it
doesn't go like that you have one Peak
Connor certainly hit his Peak so more
than likely he's on the downside however
human beings man we're we're we're okay
if I can go out there and win a title
with one [__] eye McGregor could come
back and Peete Michael Chandler not
saying it's gonna happen but it's on the
table it's a possibility well he was
sparing Ian Gary and I was pretty
impressed with that cuz Ian Gary is
legit right so you know
um depending on how that went fair play
like he he must be putting himself in
the right places to try and sharpen up
um what was your Peak what fight was
your where you felt a million
dollars oh my
God I was going to say uh the Kung Lee
fight I really really enjoyed myself in
that one but it wasn't a peak because I
had one eye do you know what I mean so
so but but like I I I guess something
like that you know around the 2014 15 16
era something like that it's weird
because we always talk about it the
mentality and the mindset of Fighters
and how the mind is so important how
fighting you know to be a great fighter
you've got to be a great thinker and you
do and the emotional side of things is
always what I struggled with not the
physical side my mind would take over I
would get angry I would get emotional I
would act like an absolute idiot once I
kind of figured that stuff out a little
bit with the help of Jason Perillo start
getting the handle on things so yeah
somewhere around there but who knows
it's funny looking back at your career
now in retrospect because there's a lot
of talk in the boxing World about
Anthony Joshua's mental uh challenges
and when I look at your career I felt
like there was like a at some point I
remember looking at you thinking there's
a slight tentativeness there that um and
then all of a sudden it went there was
something that happened with you where
that that defensive mindset went and you
became a flat out dog like that was when
we see in those Anderson Silver
performances but I was there was there a
thing that happened in the middle of all
that where you were like you know what
maybe like the Tom Aspen moment that
he's just had like where the switch was
flicked because you really did bite down
on the gumshield I started learning more
skill I I think I over complicated the
recipe do you know what I'm saying I
started overanalyzing thing and they say
paralysis by analysis you know what I
mean but may maybe there was a little
bit of that going that's Anthony Joshua
that's exactly what he's had in my
opinion yeah yeah and so that was going
on and I remember when I fought Chris
leben uh this is 2008 now he was known
for having a chin of granite and sheer
knockout power so the game plan in that
was to use my footwork and let him come
forward and just like counter him
counter him counter him and maybe that
kind of Blended in a little bit uh you
know who knows and then towards the end
I kind of got it back I remember that I
think that's why I thought that I
remember that fight so vividly because
but lean was Juiced to the [__]
guilds he was Sol you know so you mate
you you had you it wasn't fair when you
look back at that like cuz that was the
that was the Chris lean that knocked out
Vander like a proper animal yeah yeah
you know but but that that was the old
days of MMA everybody was on steroids
he's like this is what I'm going to talk
about on this show coming up tells from
the Octagon how the landscape of MMA has
changed you know back in the day when I
started nobody knew what this sport was
you know the small MMA promotions they
were all just like uh
uh they were money laundering services
do you know what I mean for like drug
dealers and gangsters and [__] like that
everyone was on [__] steroids I
wasn't because I always had the the
vision to be in the UFC you know there
were some some wild times and some funny
characters and then now it's a it's a
respected sport now people are talking
about it I mean back in the day no one
knew what UFC was none of my mates did
you know and now I live in America
granted but I get on Facebook on on a
Sunday morning my mates from back home
are talking about the UFC at the weekend
it's just amazing how far it's come you
know what I mean and now Not only was I
the champ we got Leon as a champ we got
Tom so we' got three Champions now and
and top to bottom in the UK we got so
much great talent and hopefully many
more Champs to come I mean Ian Gary is
Irish but we'll claim him you know we've
got Lon Murphy he's he's definitely got
the potential as well so it's come so
far I'm excited for that Ian Gary
potential Leon Edwards rivalry being
that they were Jim uh Bros at 1 Point
but uh Kobe Covington Leon Edwards uh
what your feelings about that right now
listen you know I mean that head kick
knockout against kamaru unbelievable
then he comes back beats him soundly in
London um what's Kobe bring to the table
that's different not much and MMA math
doesn't Stack Up it doesn't but it kind
of does in some ways you know what I
mean you can't say well this guy be that
guy so he'll beat that guy but when you
break them down kamaru who's a bigger
version of Colby he's probably a better
wrestle and he probably hits harder now
the differences that Colby brings to the
table is the pace H the output of the
strikes and the way he chains the
wrestling attacks together one after the
other after the other so he will be
relentless on Leon but Leon showed in
that in that third fight with Kamar that
he could stop the takedowns I think his
confidence has grown we know he's an
absolute sniper on the feet uh but but
it'll be a test for sure I don't because
I think also when you look at Kobe
Covington he's had two title fights now
this is his third and I think he's 36
years old and he's never been the champ
he's been an inter champ him three title
fights that's hard to get you don't get
four yeah if you do get four I'm filing
an appeal I'm having a word with Dan say
what the [__] [__] it took me to
almost 70 years old to get a shot at the
belt this bastard gets one every weekend
do you know what I mean so so I think
Kobe's going to show up it's going to be
the best version of him but but I expect
Le to do the business there's been a lot
of good points made about Colby in the
sense of he doesn't have many wins
against currently ranked guys in the
welterweight division however what I
will say is when I went back and watched
that kamaru Usman rematch he had he was
coming on strong at the end of that
fight and I actually think if he'd have
more self-belief from the the start of
the fight he may have actually cuz I
think we we had seen kamaru kind of
athletically take a turn for you know
from his Peak a little bit down still of
a fighter in the words of Floyd
Mayweather but he um I I think Colby is
is a bit more of a test than kamaru
because of what you've said about
combining the takedowns the pace and the
punches and
uh Leon's going to have to be on point
to win this fight in my opinion and it's
a great scalp for him but you know he is
talking about moving up away if he
manages it which I don't know if he has
the power to do that but that would be a
hell of a move if he managed it yeah I I
do think for kamaru he came back a
little bit too quick I respect him for
that though because you got to remember
he got head kicked he got knocked out
cold head shot dead as Leon says
spectacular put to sleep and then a few
months later he got right back into the
octagon with the same person he didn't
have a fight in between he didn't have a
fight to find his feelings again and get
his confidence back find his Mojo do you
know I me there was none of that he went
straight back in there against the guy
that just put him to sleep and I think
against hamac chimy we saw kamaru a
little bit more improved because in that
third Leon fight it wasn't a good
version and I'm not taking away from
Leon's Performance that was all Leon
that was Leon but kamaru looked a little
bit tired he looked slow he looked like
he was plotting there was a lot of talk
about his knees and maybe he was coming
to the end of his career I thought he
did wonders for his his career and his
resume and the respect that he still has
in the community with that performance
even though it was a loss against Hamza
chv and I think a lot of that the the
poor showing was of course Leon
fantastic but also the the psychological
damage of getting knocked out and going
straight back in there when I got
sparked out against you uh against Dan
Henderson UFC 100 the whole world
laughed at me every time I open social
media even still to this day I still
have people show me the memes you know
what I mean like like I give a [__] you
know what I mean but at the time you
know 14 years ago you know what I mean
yeah it haunts you a little bit and you
brush it off and you say you don't care
so that was 2009 I thought again in 2016
s years later and I think we've spoke
about this before even seven years later
and even after God knows how many fights
it was and becoming the champion and
defending the belt I still had a little
bit of like oh last time I got in the
ring with this guy he knocked me out
cold and that was separated by seven
years God knows how many fights and
become a champion kamaru went right back
in there so you got to respect that but
I also think that definitely played a
factor in that yeah on kamaru he's one
of the cool [__] I've ever
interviewed man really like the guy so
intelligent strong just funny dude
really got a lot of time with him and I
really think that he kind of showed how
human Hamza is like he made Hamza look
very okay this guy is a great guy but
he's not unbeatable uh now Hamza is
calling out the late heavyweight champ
Alex Pereira what do you make of that I
mean fair play to Hamza you know what I
mean of course he's going to do that
because he looks at Alex Pereira and he
sees a oneway ticket to be coming light
heavyweight champion Pereira is not the
best wrestler yeah Ham's a great
wrestler look at how he took down Kamar
Usman look how he's taking down
everybody picks him up has a
conversation with Dana then slams him on
the floor chokes him out didn't do it
against Gilbert didn't do it against
kamaru so you could form a narrative
that well when he stepped up in
competition he wasn't able to do that
and that's a fair thing but against uh
Alex Pereira I think he'd have his way
I'm not saying he'd win because it's a
five round fight but he' definitely be
able to get him down that's without a
shadow of a doubt now the thing is I
don't think he should get that shot but
who am I I'm not Dana White it's not my
organization if he does get the shot
great fantastic but the hardd part is
it's getting to becoming the number one
Contender it's easy to buy PR to Leap
Frog I mean Jesus Christ what is he he
was a welterweight now he's at
middleweight now he's call out the light
heavyweight champ he I [__] pick a
weight class bro I mean I love watching
the guy fight of course of course wants
to step up against Pereira number one
well we're all talking about it makes a
big headline makes him look good uh
number two as I said mainly you know
beating all the other guys that want to
become the champion scratching and
clawing your way to the top beating
other guys that are just as hungry as
you along the way to becoming the number
one Contender that's the hard part and
then and then you got to Beat the Champ
you know what I mean but to become
number one contenders a journey and a
battle all of its own let alone beating
the champion so of course per wants to
do that he wants to bypass all the
[__] and go straight for the
gold and I don't blame him no it I mean
it would be a hell of a fate to watch
but um you you mentioned the
middleweight division one man who you
fought in middleweight is cha P Sonnen
who is one of my favorite [__] people
on YouTube I love this guy right but uh
he's had a weird beef lately where to be
fair he didn't really start it uh with
jge Maz Vidal have you seen any of
this yeah so cha came on my uh my
YouTube channel last week and we had a
nice long sit down and we got into it
all because he had like a bit of an
argument with ar
helani I really love starting beef these
days you know certainly if if you
anything to do with the UFC he lies to
talk a bit of [__] about you you know
what I mean uh so Ariel and Cha were
having a disagreement I thought that was
kind of staged I did but then CH says no
it was 100% real I thought maybe they're
going to launch a podcast get everyone
to watch but no chel say no no no no no
we just we didn't appreciate each other
that day we weren't getting on and he
wound me up and he pissed me off and
then he had Jorge mazal on and I think
Ariel M stirred the PO talked a bit of
[__] and then then Jorge just came out
of nowhere talking [__] about chil so uh
I mean listen I I I've I've come on the
fire from H mazal in the past do you
know what I mean so so I ain't gonna
[__] weigh in with both feet here
Brian I know you're trying to set me up
right game bre mazal he's a [__]
Nutter mazal not a man listen I don't
need the [__] I'm a scared no I don't
give a crap but I can't be asked with
Maz Vidal coming for me every time I see
him I about that he come after me in
China he came after me in New York do
you know what I mean the
Cubano yeah yeah yeah oh dear oh dear so
so you know I heard CHS I heard CH side
of the story and uh it it came from like
a really genuine place of like I
actually really cared about this guy I
really wanted this guy to win and now
he's calling me a [__] like what the
[__] is this all about and I think a lot
of people this is just my opinion not
Mike's opinion we all loved ho there was
a period where he was on the come up he
was the coolest [__] fighter this
Scarface attitude he was like a villain
man but you rooted for him and for him
to just take on chill in such an out
right wrong way I was really [__]
disappointed in that personally but um
that's just my my opinion I'm I'm just a
podcast it's okay it's okay you know
what I mean you just trying to get CH on
your show next week you saw the numbers
I got you saw the numbers I got with ch
last week you're like I'm just I got to
get [__] CH on let's go [__] hell
um I'm going to switch uh switch up to
Darren till now our old mate um he may
be coming to my show Misfits I might be
commentating hopefully in the future
with a D until fight there's rumors of
Mike Perry and I just wanted to know
what you thought of that move it it's a
bit of a shame to same Le the UFC when I
thought he performed in retrospect when
you look at the drier stupis fight I
might have pronounce that wrong because
I was [__] his name up um I thought he
did better than a lot of people do
against trickers actually and you know
kind of at the time it was seen as oh
another loss for Darren but in reality
he really had drick us in a lot of
trouble in that fight so yeah what do
you make of his move to Misfits
potentially well well first of all
that's a great point that you make
because I think that fight has aged very
very well certainly when you see what
driers did against Robert Whitaker and
as we all know Robert whiter outside of
vizzy and now it's changed because of
Strickland was the next best guy okay I
always spoke so highly about Darren and
his fighting ability you know and I I
used to get [__] off so many people you
know just because he's English or
whatever I'm like no I I know what
Darren's capable of I've seen him fight
he's absolutely fantastic granted some
Fighters were able to expose a
deficiency in the wrestling or whatever
like a Derek Brunson or whatever but on
the feet man he can compete with all of
them right so stepped away from the UFC
he's taking a little time away I think
he wants to not be wrestling as much and
let his knees heal up and all the rest
of it so fair play to him you know
whatever makes him happy I'm so great to
hear about this I hope the fight goes
down I think him and Mike Perry will be
fantastic uh I mean Mike Perry is
nowhere near as technical as Darren till
Darren's listen I'm telling you man
Darren till could be a professional
boxer right he's a very very good boxer
he's got very fast hands he's got a lot
of power and he's a mean son of a [__]
as well but so's Mike Perry Mike Perry's
a mental patient of the highest degree
do you know what I mean Mike Perry
couldn't get a win streak together in
the UFC then he goes off to Bear knuckle
and he's smashing everybody knocking
Luke Rocko's teeth out McGregor was
squaring up against him in the ring do
you know what I mean Mike Perry's found
his niche in bare knuckle that's his
thing actual boxing I don't know about
that yeah you know as as you know
yourself uh you know yourself Mike uh
the boxing is a bit more Technical and
you can't just uh you know go in there
wailing because because you you
obviously have so much more protection
from those big [__] gloves and I I I
expect Darren to do fantastically well
in Misfits personally I think he's going
to do real good yeah there's been a bit
of talk lately about one UFC fighter was
twerking after her fight promoting her
only fans and I just wanted to know what
your opinion was on the the the modern
phenomena which is female Fighters
generally this is in boxing MMA doing
only fans fair play to him fair play to
him why not yeah why not in this modern
society that we live in if they can find
a way to crack the coal to game the
system to get money right fair play to
him now I know some people might
discredit that some people might it
might not be there flavor might not be
there at taste you know what I mean I
used to work at factories mate for £365
an hour do you know what I mean it's
hard to make a b do you know what I mean
it's [__] hard man I used to work at
factories and come out black black from
head to toe with just my eyes popping
out working at a bloody Char sorry you
know those disposable barbecues making
them in the [__] Hopper covered in
charcoal head to toe I used to slaughter
cows do you know what I mean minimum
wage right I've done every [__] job
under the planet if they can sit there
and only fans and get paid a ton of D
fair play God bless him I I don't know
if this is true but I've heard Britney
Palmer gets like 50 Grand a month for
like just showing pictures of her toes
do you know what I mean I don't get the
whole toe fetish thing it's not my vibe
but God bless her listen I'll tell you
right now if anyone wants pictures of my
toes and they're gonna pay me big time
money I'll do it sign me up I haven't
got my shoes on right now I'll give you
a little sneak peek here we oh oh no
I'm pretty sure we've got some we've got
some free m don't wor no listen listen
all jokes are side all as aside hey it's
a hard world it's a hard world my son
just finished College recently you know
he's got a master's degree in business
and he's trying to figure it out what he
wants to do what what his next step is
currently he's applying for like
internships and stuff like that he's
working at some crappy restaurant at the
minute and he's hating life and in a way
I'm kind of glad because life is tough
and he's learning that you know he's
learning that wow you know the the value
of a do you're making him do that though
aren't you you're you're not you're
you're you're part of that learning
aren't you because I know you you've
done well so if you wanted to make it
easy you could but you are you trying to
help him learn
that well well I mean I I help I help
with his rent and stuff like that but he
can kiss my he's [__] 22 mate he's 22
years old he's 20 too it's time you were
going to say kiss
my no you you've got you've got to learn
the value of a dollar do you know what I
mean so anyway going back to the
original question life is hard and he's
learning that right now and he's
learning What It Takes I mean it's hard
just to keep a roof over your head it's
hard to pay the bills you know what I
mean inflation the cost of living I mean
the average people in the street are
really struggling just to put the
[__] heating on do you know what I
mean so if these women can go out there
crack the system and get paid a ton of
though some might not like it so what
back in the day you know times change
mate so what God bless him I know Andrew
Tate might get on his [__] high horse
but who gives a [__] what Andrew Tate
says [__]
hell you and Sean Strickland agree on
that for sure I've just seen a clip of
Sean Strickland going on this [__]
pimp U but you know what it's mad for me
is is I know your story like I have
literally from The Ultimate Fight of
season 3 watching you you come through
the doors I've seen you from that moment
onwards and I've like in real time
followed your journey there's comments
of me from interviews you've done in
2009 saying I wanted to meet you right
so like I'm I've been there watching
this and to see the guy you were as the
guy who slept in his car outside of this
old gym and his Ms was trying our best
to help pay uh the way to build this
stream for you to now sit there in your
lovely house in LA to go my son has a
degree in
business well done mate that's big time
that that is [__] great well done
yeah Bri and it is it is you know
because he's living up in San Francisco
you know good I mean that's incredible
by itself he's he's got a degree in
business marketing and hopefully he's
going to go go on and do big things my
daughter she has a a passion for acting
she's studying theater studies and she
she's at acting class almost every
bloody day you know she's going to some
fancy ledar College which G to cost me
an absolute arm and a leg because
because I do do a little bit of the
acting stuff as well lordy D lordy D
what yeah yeah but but like because I I
do a little bit of the acting stuff but
that's not why I'm bringing this up I
always say to uh to to my wife because
my daughter again like a lot of young
people she didn't know what she wanted
to do she didn't know what direction she
was in and then she went through an old
breakup and I said well what about just
go through do some acting classes
because it can be very it can be very
the therapeutic
and uh she she's developed a big passion
and a love for it and she's really taken
it seriously and who knows who knows
maybe she never does anything you know
but at least now she's got a dream and I
believe it's important for people to
have a dream and I said to Rebecca I
said listen with this acting stuff that
I do even though I really enjoy it and I
got a couple of big projects coming out
got two big films next year Den a
Thieves 2 red Sonia baby uh and
hopefully my first lead coming up but I
said if nothing else comes out of that
that I've just been able to instill a
dream and find the passion for my
daughter then that's that in itself has
been worth it all yeah I'm I mean um
looking at you as a dad from the outside
in I see you as a great dad right you
you you're wrestling your son and we see
all these funny little moments between
your youngest and who' religiously pick
against you and your daughter just seems
like a carbon copy of your wife uh and
you seem to have a real great family set
up but out of all of the three kids uh
just cuz I'm trying to understand what
it takes for you to to sort of get
annoyed at them which one is it who will
really make you raise your voice uh and
and
why well well in a minute I'm about to
spaz out because they're all I'm we're
doing this interview and they have no
respect I can hear them banging around
the house Callum my eldest he came he's
back he's just come back it's
Thanksgiving in America so it's
Thanksgiving on Thursday so everything
shuts down for the week pretty much uh
so he just came back from college and uh
he went out with his mates last night he
get a few drinks come back at half three
in the morning right came back at half
three in the morning and we've just got
a sauna installed and he walks in at
half three in the morning he wakes me up
right and and I'm not gonna be that guy
I'm not gonna start shouting or anything
like I couldn't care less I'm happy for
him but I couldn't get back to sleep and
then they were in there and then they
went outside in the garden and I'm like
what they are they getting in the bloody
SAA what are they doing do you know and
it's like it's a it's a five man saw it
it's like glass walls and stuff it's
beautiful but I'm like they're all big
dudes right callum's like two 65 you
know what I mean it's like 130 kilos
yeah he's massive right I'm like these
big dudes all pissed up in a glass sauna
by the swimming pool that's that's a
recipe for disaster so I'm like hey
caral what are you doing looks like a
very dodgy party at this point at 3 a.m.
yeah no it does it does you know what I
mean I'm like get out the S I said also
if you've had a few drinks you're going
to be dehydrated even more you're going
to feel like you're going to feel like
death in the morning so anyway um anyway
to answer your question he's the one
yeah yeah CU you know why cuz he's 22 he
came in from college the other night I
could send you the video it's hilarious
because as you say we're always
wrestling he comes in I've dieted down a
bit I'm the lest I've been for a while
and he goes come on dad come on and
grabs All of Me and starts having a
wrestle [__] hell he slammed me to
the floor right he I got up he did it
again cuz like you know I mean I was
taking it easy do you know what I mean
but yeah he was just throwing me around
absolute rag doll But to answer your
question because he is 22 he he has to
push me on everything he has to disagree
with everything he has he's he's got his
college education do you know what I
mean so like he disagrees I'm like
listen I pay the bills this is how it is
right so shut the [__] up right stop
arguing with me just for one minute for
crying out loud because guess what I
still got it baby uh that was Mel Bing
on the TR J podcast once again do check
his show out the link for the shows to
buy your tickets to go and see him and
the heavyweight champion of the world
and also many others will be in the link
description below go and see Mike watch
the show it's fantastic the last one was
unbelievable the second one will be even
better no doubt big thanks for coming on
mate appreciate you mate anytime
[Music]
mate